[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: Welcome
to another episode
of "VM End-to-End," a show where
we have a former, maybe even
reformed VM skeptic and a
VM enthusiast, my friend
Brian, together to hash
out all things VMs.
Brian, thank you for being here.
What is this episode about?
You just told me it's
special, I had to be here,
and that was it.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, I think
you're going to like this.
It's where I admit that VMs
might not always be the answer.
CARTER MORGAN: Can you
say that one more time?
BRIAN DORSEY: VMs might
not always be the answer.
It depends.
And so with that
in mind, I wanted
to bring in an expert
colleague of ours
who has been a
sysadmin, who has run
all kinds of different
machines, and who's
now focused on serverless.
Welcome, Katie.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Hello.
Thank you for
inviting me, Brian.
CARTER MORGAN: Yes.
And Katie, I'm extra excited.
I don't know if
you-- yeah, you just
heard what Brian said
about maybe VMs not always
being the answer.
Didn't you get to play around
with the Migrate for Cloud Run
tooling?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: I did.
Brian, have you
heard about this one?
It's very cool.
BRIAN DORSEY: Honestly,
I think I heard about it.
And let me make sure I'm right.
Is this the thing
that claims to be
able to make
containerized setups out
of what's running on a VM?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
Yes, and it works.
I've tried it.
BRIAN DORSEY: Wait, OK.
OK, I have to admit, I
was so skeptical of this.
It's so much often
considered an anti-pattern.
And you can't just lift this
whole VM into a container.
Containers aren't VMs,
all this sort of stuff,
that I didn't actually look at
it as carefully as I probably
should, because it didn't
pass my is-this-real test.
So how was I wrong about that?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: I had
the same sort of thought.
It's like, but if I've
got a complex VM that's
got all these different
services-- some of them
are socket-driven,
some of them are
port-driven-- how am I
going to take that from a VM
and put it into a container?
But I found that it was
actually really cleverly done.
What I did was, I built a very
special bespoke crystalline VM,
and I installed Postgres
from system packages.
I set that all up.
I set up a Django
website on there.
I had a whole bunch of
user uploads on there.
So it was a very bespoke VM.
And then I ran it through
Migrate for Cloud Run.
And that was able to
containerize the VM,
identify what
services were running.
And then I had the choice
to disable all the services
and then re-create them.
Well, not recreate,
redefine the services.
There's a particular YAML
that you can define--
services-confic.yaml-- where,
like you would define a whole
bunch of systemd services,
you can define new services.
So I disable all
the services that's
running on this
containerized VM.
And then I declare a
new one, which is just
my web service on a port.
And then when that's
running in Cloud Run,
all I do is say, see that port?
Go listen to that.
One thing I did find, though--
that this worked really
well when combining it with
the database migration service.
So I could take my
locally-running Postgres
database and then migrate
that into Cloud SQL.
So I could migrate my VM twice.
But it meant that I was
able to go from one very
special VM that if it went
away, I'd be very sad,
into managed Cloud SQL and
then into a container in Cloud
Run that can scale to
zero, survive restarts, all
that kind of fun.
It was actually really neat.
I'm interested in
sharing more about that
to some of our customers.
CARTER MORGAN:
There's two things
I want to ask about here.
One, first, you
defined the mapping
between ports and
sockets and whatnot.
But two, you said
that you had a VM,
or you wrote a
custom bespoke VM,
and then you transitioned it
into a more managed service.
Why?
Why would you go up
the stack that way?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Well,
Carter, what do you
want to have to worry about?
CARTER MORGAN: Me, personally?
Nothing.
I want to write code, and
I want to be done with it.
That's what I want
to worry about.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: For
brand-new greenfield projects
or proof-of-concept
projects, you
can do that straight away
with Cloud Run, where
it's such an abstraction
on top of the VM
on top of the Kubernetes
on top of everything.
You just need to containerize
your code and go run it.
But there are going to
be brownfield projects
where you're going to have
something that exists.
And if you want to pull it
up into a serverless system,
you're going to have to
do that migration step.
But with managed
services, you don't
have to worry about
a number of things.
Like, who were you talking
with the other day?
Was it Gabe?
About databases?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yes, it was.
He talked to us about
databases, hosted,
how to decide when
to host on a VM,
and some database
migration stuff.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah, in
my bespoke virtual machine,
I would have to worry about
maintenance and system package
updates, and backups
of my database.
Once I'm in Cloud SQL,
that's all there by default.
What do you want to
have to worry about?
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
Well, let's get an example.
Let's ground it in reality.
Say one of our two
co-hosts on this show
was writing a small
back-end application.
No front end.
It just uses APIs, goes from
a command-line type deal.
Where would I want to run that?
Or, sorry, where would our
co-host, whoever it is,
want to run that?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Well, Carter
and/or Brian, it depends.
It sounds like you may not even
have to worry about Cloud Run,
because with Cloud
Run, you would
have to have a container
that listens on a port
and then serves stuff.
But it sounds like if
you've just got a function,
you might just
want to go straight
to Cloud Functions,
where you just
supply a function,
a method, a function
description with parameters.
And then it gives you--
it returns data.
And just copy, paste that
up into Cloud Functions,
and everything else
is handled for you.
CARTER MORGAN: Mm-hmm.
Can I ask a question?
Brian, I see that you've
got something on your mind,
so let me sneak this one in.
I'm very used to with, say,
Kubernetes, just putting
a web app in a container
and running that.
What is the difference
between Cloud Run, which
I'm not really familiar with,
and something like a Kubernetes
there?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Cloud Run
is just managed Kubernetes.
Shh.
CARTER MORGAN: Oh, so
then GKE, basically.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
Yeah, Cloud Run
runs on top of
Knative, which itself
runs on top of GKE, which
itself runs on top of VMs, which
itself runs in Google
data centers, which itself
runs on servers.
You don't have to worry
about so many things
when you move up this
abstraction stack.
You're still using the
underlying technology,
but you don't have
to worry about it.
BRIAN DORSEY: I
love what you just
said there-- abstraction stack.
I like to think about it--
you talk about Cloud Run, and
we've got App Engine and--
or, sorry.
You were talking
about functions,
and we've got App Engine
and Cloud Run and Kubernetes
and VMs.
And like you said, if you've
got a greenfield thing,
you probably want to start at
the top of this abstraction
stack and work your way down.
And if you have something
existing that's already
running in a VM or on
a computer somewhere,
it's probably going
to be easiest to start
towards the bottom.
Nice.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
Yeah, it's very nice.
I remember, back
in the day, if I
wanted to try to get
logs or debug a machine,
I would have to physically go
to the data center and wheel
out a little trolley and
plug in a keyboard and mouse.
Nowadays, depending on
where in the stack I am,
I either SSH directly
into the machine,
or I go into Cloud Logging, and
everything is already there.
I don't have to physically drive
to where my machine is anymore.
I don't have to
worry about that.
My life is very much
better now I do not
have to physically go and
plug in keyboard and mouse
into servers.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
Yeah, I can relate to this.
Being in the military, I used to
work on some very old computer
technology.
I'm glad I don't have to
deal with that anymore.
But there's something I wanted
to dig into a little bit
deeper here.
Your thought process
behind thinking about,
well, what do you want
to have to worry about,
and what do you have to manage--
is that based on what resources
the application is touching?
For example, if
the application is
touching a web port
or a WebSocket,
then you might have to use Cloud
Run as opposed to a serverless.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: It depends.
If you have a system that
relies on specific GPUs,
you might have to
choose a service
where you can define those.
The Cloud Run container
contract is just, tell me
what port on this container
I should listen on,
and I will serve that for you.
You can have anything you
want inside that container.
I have colleagues
that have put Fortran
into that container and
COBOL into that container.
As long as it listens
on a port, it's fine.
But if you need
to start worrying
about not just one container,
but multiple containers,
you might want to
drop down into GKE
and handle your
orchestration at that level.
If you want to have to worry
about specific types of CPU
architecture, you might
need to drop down into VMs.
But if all you
want to do is, when
someone goes to my HTTP URL,
they get back a response,
then some of these
higher-level abstractions
are going to be the
solution for you.
But you don't just
have to choose one.
You can mix and match.
CARTER MORGAN: Ooh, Brian.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK,
so actually I'm
inspired by Katie's
picture-painting here,
and the it depends.
So what if we--
we'll keep with
the theme of VMs,
because that's
this conversation.
But compare and contrast.
If you were going to
use functions versus VM,
when would you use
functions instead?
When would you choose a VM?
When would you combine them?
And go through the whole
abstraction stack one at a time
and dig into each.
CARTER MORGAN: I am
so here for this,
because as soon
as you said that,
my first question was, oh, wait.
I can use serverless
and VMs together
in the same application?
What?
Is that a thing?
So yes, I want to go,
and I want to find out
what tools I can use in place,
or begrudgingly with, VMs,
if that's what I need to do.
BRIAN DORSEY: Awesome.
Katie, would you be
up for coming back
and dig deeper on some of these?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
(CHANTING) Season 3.
Season 3.
I'd love to.
BRIAN DORSEY: Take
that as a yes.
CARTER MORGAN: Season 3.
Well, if you're
watching at home,
I just want to say, thanks for
sticking with us for so long.
Next season, it
sounds like we're
going to go on a little
bit of an adventure
and explore different use cases
for some of these abstractions
on top of VMs and when you
might want to use them.
So thank you so much.
Katie, thank you for being here.
Brian, as always, thank you.
Yo.
So if you are at
home watching this,
I'm sure there's a couple things
that we talked about today
that maybe spurred your
thoughts, some questions
that you have about
VMs and using them
with some of these different
tools and services.
So drop those in the comments.
We'll check those out.
And stick around,
because next season,
it's going to get weird.
That's "VM End-to-End."
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]